hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar
what are the important considerations
for centrifugation in the bioprocess
workflow
i am michelle ashton of labyrinths and
i'll be your moderator
for today's event today's educational
web seminar
is presented by zlabert brought to you
by thermo fisher scientific
to learn more visit thermofisher.com
let's get started before we begin i
would like to remind everyone that this
event
is interactive we encourage you to
participate
by submitting as many questions that you
want at any time you want during the
presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask
question box and click send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation
please click on the support tab found at
the top right
of the presentation window or report
your problem
by clicking on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
this presentation is educational and
thus
offers continuing education credits
please click
on the continuing education credits tab
located at the top
right of the presentation window and
follow the process
to obtain your credits i now present
today's speaker
ben hualimon bio process application
specialist
floor model centrifuges at thermo fisher
for a complete biography on our speaker
please visit the biography tab
at the top of your screen then you may
now begin your presentation
welcome
thank you hello everyone and thanks
again for joining today webinar
about important consideration for sound
segregation
in the bioprocess workflow
my name is benuali moore and i'm working
for thermo fisher scientific
as a bioprocess application specialist
for floor model
science refuges
the presentation is composed of three
sections
and will last for about 30 to 40 minutes
your questions will be answered after
the presentation
for the remaining of the time
the section one is the bio process
applications
where the refugees play an important
part
the section two is the important
considerations
for sound situation in the bio process
workflow
and ways a centrifuge addresses these
considerations
the section three is the thermo fischer
scientific
bioprocess science refugees
let us start with section one and take a
closer look
at the bioprocess workflow and what
are harvests clarification
and purification concentration
polar polishing steps in which sounds
refugees
play an important part
let us first remind what is
bioprocess again
that is a specific process that uses
complete living cells to obtain
a desired products the cells are used
as a factory to produce the product of
interest
the process is made of upstream
and downstream processes which are
defined
in the next slide
the upstream process is the entire
process
from early cell isolation and
cultivation
the cell banking and culture expansion
of the cells
until termination of the culture and
collection of the live
cell batch at the end of the upstream
the batch volume may range from one
liter
up to ten thousand meters depending on
the scale
and contain the product of interest the
culture media
and other particles
the downstream process is the entire
process
concentrating and purifying the product
of interest
to meet purity and quality requirements
it is usually divided in successive
steps
the separation of the biomass also
called
our vets in which country should may
play an
important part the self-description
if the product of interest is
intracellular
the separation of the cell debris also
called
clarification in which centrifuge may
play an
important part the purification
concentration and polishing
in which the sounds refute may also play
an important part
and finally the formulation and the
packaging
in the downstream process the harvest
is the separating and the collecting
of the product of interest from the
cultural media
the process volume may range from one
meter
to 10 000 liters depending on the
process scale
refuge may play an important part in the
harvest
step
in the downstream process the
clarification is the removing of liquid
micro size
substances from the product of interest
process volume may range from 100
milliliters
to 1000 meters depending on the process
scale
and the harvest method the front refuge
may play an important part in the
step
in the downstream process the
purification
concentration polishing is the removing
of
liquid nano size substances from the
product of interest
process volume may range from 10
milliliters to
100 liters depending on process scale
and clarification method concrete huge
may also play an important part
in the purification concentration
polishing step
for example in cell therapy
manufacturing
the science research may play an
important car to harvest
and concentrate the cells usually
it is world cell separation at low g
force the wall cell is the product of
interest
no damage on the cell is key
the workflow is media preparation build
cultivation
better invest and concentration in
within which the centrifuge may play an
important part
then the buffer exchange and following
steps
in the case of gene therapy
manufacturing
the centrifuge may play an important
part a different step
of the process first
used in the microbial cell separation at
me g-force to harvest either the
intracellular
or the extracellular product of interest
for the preparation
of the dna vector then used in the main
process
as their cell transfection and
structure expansion at low g
force to harvest the product of interest
from the world center
then at mid g4 to clarify the product of
interest
and finally a high g force
in combination with other techniques to
purify
and concentrate the product of interest
for monoclonal antibodies manufacturing
when considering the product of interest
is intracellular
the centrifuge may play an important
part to harvest
at low g-force the cell biomass planet
and then to clarify at me geforce the
supernatant
containing the product of interest from
the cell biomass pellet
music
in the case of egg-based viral vaccine
manufacturing
contributes may play an important part
to clarify
at new g-force the anatomic fluid
containing the virus of interest
from the undrained egg and then
concentrate
and purify at high g-force
the virus of interest from the
unanswered fluid
when looking at cell-free protein
expression manufacturing
the sanctuary church may play an
important part to remove components
like nucleus or vacuole of the cell
at various g4s
let us continue with section 2
discussing
how the centrifuge addresses the
contamination control
the scalability the compliance
the flexibility and the availability
important considerations in the
bioprocess workflow
here is now section 2a the contamination
control important consideration
the control of the contamination is
important
because it can endanger all types of
cell culture and the consequences
range from well at least mild workflow
disturbances
to total paralysis of the productivity
within the facility
as you know the relatively large numbers
of contaminants
circulating in the most environments
increases likelihood of contamination
breaching any barriers protecting the
bioprocess
sometimes contamination is not easy to
recognize
so the best strategy is usually based on
prevention
with a reduction of contamination where
it does appear
to control contamination in the batch
contribute
one should ensure that the content the
containers
are clean and sterilized by performing
cleaning
and decontamination validation or using
single-use sterilized ready-to-use
contacts
the containers should be manipulated in
a clean air environment
when loading and emptying the solution
and also the use of a closed system
as possible
to control contamination in a zonal or
continuous close
refuge one should ensure that the
product path
is clean and sterilized by also
performing cleaning and decontamination
validation
or using senior use sterilized and ready
to use containers
as sound instead in addition
the system should be designed to present
potential leaks especially
at the union sim drives
when performing the harvest and
clarification
steps to control contamination when
using
a sound refuge please consider the
following
the use of sterilized single-use
companies
and assembly sets it comes with
sterilities that is the gate
it is ready to use and no post-use
cleaning
the use of closed system it reduces
the risk of contamination the use of
cleaning services
outside partners exist to clean and
sterilize containers
with certification
when performing the purification
concentration
polishing steps to control contamination
when using a centrifuge
please consider the following
use an integrated process control it
provides
an automated closed system process
and maintain pressure additions across
the union seat joints to reduce
risk of contamination
use a system capable of coolant
manipulation
as well as clean in place cip
and steam place sip to ensure sterilized
condition
use system with level of weight of
coolant and lubricant
fluids monitoring device to detect leaks
and stop the process
use system equipped with hepa filter on
the hotter
chamber to prevent possible contaminants
to escape to the environment
here is now section 2b the scalability
consideration
the scalability can either be scale up
down meaning the changes the volume
of a set equipment quantity the
equipment goes
bigger or smaller to process more
or less volume scale
out in meaning changes
changing the quantity of a set equipment
volume
the number of equipment was plus or
minus
to process more or less volume
the linearity is important to ensure the
same process parameters apply
throughout the different scale of the
process
to perform scalability in the maps from
contribution
one can change the container volume and
paying attention to keep the same
geometry k factor
and separation total g-force
or change the container quantity which
is obviously
not impacting the separation parameters
in a zonal continuous flow centrifuge
one can change the rotor volume
keeping the septuagint parameters
and there is done short time the same
when performing the harvest and
clarification steps
to scale the process when using the
centrifuge
please consider the following the choice
of container volume
and the choice of hotel mountaineer
capacity
when performing the purification
concentration
polishing steps to scale the process
when using a centrifuge
please consider the choice of water and
core volume
with same particle separation in
addition
fast length the linear capability is
ensured
by adjusting the process flow rate
here is now section 2c the compliance
important consideration
the compliance to quality and regulatory
is an important consideration because it
controls the strategy to manage the
production
processes within an established design
space
it controls the data integrity the
trustability
the validation and the certification
to perform a compliant process
when using centrifuge one should ensure
that the hardware
is compliant to standard to safety
standard
compliance to trustability with the
necessary software for batch data report
and audit trail
compliant to connectivity with user
management
time synchronization data archive
and system backup compliant to iso
certified
manufacturing
to perform a compliance process when
using centrifuge
one should ensure that the product
contact well is
compliant to certification with the usb
class six for example
compliant to extractable and initiable
in-room manufacturing with eml testing
compliance with trustability validation
that are sterilized with certificate
compliant to iso certified manufacturing
when performing the harvest
clarification
purification concentration polishing
steps
to perform a compliant process when
using a sound refuge
please consider the following the choice
of quantum material
the necessary certification for product
combat parks
the necessary certification for
equipment
the availability of sorry
the availability of qualification
services
the availability of transability
software and connectivity
here is now section 2d the flexibility
important consideration
a flexible manufacturing space allows a
facility to operate at different scales
and or produce multiple products
without too much cost and f4 change out
a flexible process can respond to
challenges
such as new projects
a project that comes from an acquisition
partnership or merger
and all without requiring any
complacency
adjustments
to maximize flexibility when using some
refuge
one should review the capability of the
equipment to process
a range of volume a range of separation
g-force and a range of separation
type to cover various applications
such as different cell type and
different step of the workflow
and to adapt to various process
variations
such as different cell culture density
turbinity
and cell strain
when performing the harvest and
clarification steps
to maximize the process flexibility when
using a centrifuge
please consider the choice of selectable
g-force
separation time temperature acceleration
and deceleration adjustments
when performing the purification
concentration
polishing steps to maximize the process
flexibility when using the centrifuge
please also consider the choice of
selectable g-force
separation time temperature acceleration
and deceleration adjustment
and in addition the ability of an
integrated process control
to optimize and automatize the loading
the separation the collection the
cleaning
and the decontamination of the process
here is now section two e the
readability
important consideration
is an important consideration because it
describes
as the belief forming processes that
produces either
more secure beliefs or higher ratio of
two to five billions therefore
the proper handling and maintenance of
the equipment is
key to ensure the most uptime
to optimize reliability when using sound
refuge
one should follow the container cleaning
the decontamination the inspection
and the lifetime good practice
as well as the hotel balancing the water
inspection
the equipment cleaning and maintenance
good practices
when performing the harvest
clarification purification
concentration polishing steps
to optimize relativity process when
using the centrifuge
please consider the following the cons
the container maximum usage
the hotter extended warranty the author
inspection
services the training
the maintenance and the requalification
services
let us finish with section 3
representing the thermo fisher
scientific range of bioprocess
some refugees
thermo fisher scientific offers a range
of bio processing research
addressing the need for harvest
clarification
and purification concentration
coloration
steps in the bio process workflow
for harvesting the thermos scientific
server
bios 16 centrifuge for harvesting and
clarifying
the thermos scientific survival bios a
centrifuge
the lynx 4000 and the link's
6 000 super speed contributions
for purifying concentrating and
polishing
the thermal scientific servo wx plus
the cc40 snx and the cc40
nx extra speed contributors
the thermoscientific so-called bio-16
sanskrit huge
is a batch centrifuge specific for cell
culture harvest
with minimum investments and food trends
the thermos scientific servo bios
excellent refuge
is also a bad batch centrifuge
with minimum investment and footprint
but
with higher g-force capable of both
the cell culture harvest and the
clarification
the thermal scientific survival means
super speed centrifuge is a batch
and a continuous for centrifuge for
clarification
of microsized particles
the thermal scientific solved by w
x plus cc 40 s and x
and cc 40 nx ultra speed centrifuge
are batch and continuous fluorescent
refuge
for purification of nano sized particles
like virus for manufacturing vaccines
with linear scale up from rnd
to pilots to commercial gmp production
the thermoscientific servo bios 16th
centrifuge
has capacity up to 16 meters
in one liter and two liters bottle for
mammalian
east and bacteria separation
the thermoscientific solval bios a
centrifuge
has capacity up to 10 meters in one
liter bottles
for also many year yeast and bacteria
separation
but at a higher g-force
the thermal survival sorry
the thermostatistic solver links super
speed centrifuge
is a batch with both up to one liter
and a continuous flow up to over 40
000 g4 centrifuge for clarification
of micro sized particles
the thermoscientific server wx plus
6040 ethernet and cc40 and its ultra
speeds and refugees
are batch and continuous and refugees
for purification of nano-sized particles
usually using the density gradient
separation
technique in batch of
1 liter up to 100 liters
please visit us on
wealthwrite.thermofisher.com
slash flex for what's next to learn more
about thermo fisher scientific
bioprocessing refugees
with application notes tips brochures
and more
this is now the end of the presentation
thank you all for joining
well thank you ben for your informative
presentation
we'll now start the live q a portion of
the webinar
if you have a question you'd like to ask
please do so now
just click on the ask a question box
located on the far
left of your screen and we'll answer as
many questions as we have time for
all right let's go ahead and get started
okay ben your first question
is what is the preferred process
volume when harvesting with thermos
with thermo fisher scientific storehold
bio 16 centrifuge
all right yeah thank you for the
question
so the the thermal scientific servo
bios 16 centrifuge is a batch
contribute and it has a maximum capacity
of 16 liters and
a maximum force of little over 7000
g this sounds refuge
is capable to accept six or eight
times the one liter or the two liters
bottle
uh one cycle lasts for about 15 to 30
minutes
and therefore it's designed to process
from one liter up to a few hundred
liter of cell culture
great thank you all right your next
question
what is the difference between
thermoscientific
sorval bios a centrifuge and
lynx super speed series centrifuges
okay so the the thermal scientific
solved bios
sounds refuge is specific
for the bio process applications
it is capable to spin 10 bottles of
1 liter up to 10 000 g
the typical application is harvest and
clarification of cell culture
as the thermoscientific server links
super speed contribution
is a is a versatile machine as it comes
with a wide range of hotels
for not only by your process
applications
in case of bio process application it
can
spin portals up to
20 000 g4 in a batch hotel
and samples a little over
40 thousand engine a continuous flow
rotor
but the links super speed control huge
has a large range of photos
for many other applications as well
okay the next question what is the
typical
application for the thermo scientific
sorval
cc40nx ultra speed series
centrifuges and how is it different from
other centrifuges
so the uh the thermoscientific servo
cc40nx crossfit sounds research
is unique uh
by the uh the vertical tubular rotor
and it's capable of liquid liquid
separation
as well as liquid solid separation
of the nano-sized particles
in continuous flow for the gmp
application
the separated material can withdraw
and analyze online for automated closed
system process so it is
unique in in this case and it's mostly
used
in the vaccine purification
workflow at
various scales so the rnd scale as the
pilot and the commercial industrial
scale
and it's also used in the gene therapy
for the capsid full and empty collision
thank you ben all right we've got one
last question for you here
is a traceability software available to
support
gmp applications
so yes of course the trustability
software is available across
the full range of the thermoscientific
centrifuges
[Music]
and the software is delivering
the user management the audit trail
and the batch data reports and the
software supports most of the gmp
application requirements
thanks again ben and do you have any
final comments for our audience before
we close today
yeah thank you for for listening here
and feel free to contact uh
my mail my mailbox directly
if any question or fallout
thanks again ben for your time today and
for your important research
and we would also like to thank lavroots
and our sponsor thermo fisher scientific
for underwriting today's educational
webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their questions
again any questions we did not have time
for today and those submitted during the
on-demand period
will be addressed by then via the
contact information you provided
at the time of registration this webcast
can be viewed on demand
and labyrinths will alert you via email
when it's available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event
until next time take care goodbye
you